The fourth Final Destination opens with a
race car accident, so as you can imagine,
the scene is loaded up with references and
easter eggs hidden in the many advertisements
plastered on the cars and around the speedway.
The car that was responsible for the accident
was Car 6.
Each opening disaster in the previous movies
has referenced Hell or the devil.
From any almost any given angle you can see
three 6s on the car, representing the Devil’s
number, and the hellfire decals represent
the fiery inferno.
This car has a number of ads on it, including
Brand X, the same brand of vehicle that would
eventually take out the mechanic, Andy.
There’s also a Brand X racing poster in
the security guards office.
There are a lot of Xs in this movie.
The goth hair stylist, Deedee, has an X tattoo
on her arm, the main character Nick has an XBOX, and the characters Hunt and Janet
are ex-boyfriend and girlfriend.
The recurring Xs may be an homage to the special
effects company that did most of the effects
on this movie.
Another decal seen on this car and many of
the others is this one, for Heck Race Shifts,
created by Ryan Heck, the assistant art director.
There’s also a banner for Heck Race Shifts
where we see their slogan: “Performance,
Get it in Gear.”
Nick has a premonition later on where his
girlfriend Lori is grinded up by an escalator
gear.
There’s also some text on the car’s hood,
“Feel the rush”, which could be a sign
of the violent stampede out of the stadium
when the crash first occurs.
That’s just the first car in the first scene.
There is so.
Much.
More.
And I’ll be covering it all, so stick around
to the end of this video.
Directorial duties for The Final Destination
would… for some reason… be turned back
over to Final Destination 2’s director,
David R Ellis.
And he didn’t really innovate a whole lot.
Last time he brought us the Route 23 pile-up
so this time the opener is… another pile-up
but this time it’s at a race track?
Aside from that, there’s definitely a miscommunication
about the tone of the franchise between these
two directors.
Wong’s movies kind of have some emotional
depth to the characters, while Ellis seems
entirely focused on goofy over the top kills.
It’s easy to understand why.
Wong was promoted to the director’s chair
as a writer, and Ellis’s background was
as a stunt coordinator.
One thing they did get down between the two
of them, was lots and lots of Things You Missed.
But before we get back into them, this
is my last Raycon ad read of the year, so
let’s go back over some of the best moments.
Like when I told you all the reasons you should
pick up Raycons.
“You'll get six hours of playtime, seamless Bluetooth
pairing, more bass, a more compact design
that gives you a nice noise isolating fit.”
And that time I told if you if they make good
as a holiday gift or not.
“They make a great holiday gift cause you
can use them anytime anywhere.”
So many great Raycon memories, and there’s
about to be an even greater one.
Raycon’s being generous for the holidays,
they’re offering all my viewers 15-percent
off right now!
Click the link in the description box or go
to buyraycon.com/czsworld to get 15% off your
Raycon purchase!
The first thing you’ll hear when you start
watching The Final Destination is the song
Devour by Shinedown.
Unlike previous movies, there isn’t a diegetic
Death omen song, that is, one that the characters
can hear.
But the lyrics are still kind of relevant.
Like this line: “Smash it and crash it and
thrash it and trash it.
You know they're only toys!”
There would soon be a lot of smashing and
crashing, and we do see a toy version of the
main car involved in that crash later on at
the mall, when our characters walk by the
Megatech booth.
Remember, the race that ended in tragedy was
called the Megatech 300.
And that race was held at McKinley Speedway.
I pointed out the meaning behind that name
and the many locations with the McKinley moniker
in my Final Destination 3 video.
Let’s look at some of the other cars involved
in the race.
Most of these appear on multiple cars or in
multiple places in the stadium, so I’ll
just be mentioning where I first noticed each
one.
The red Car 71 has a phone number on it which
contains the number 180, a reference to Flight
180 from the first movie.
The characters are also sitting in Section
180 in the stands.
“Tell me again why we chose this over seeing
the movie.”
They do end up seeing the movie later.
This is a clue about another one of the disasters.
Car 51 is a red and white vehicle with lots
of stickers.
This one says Hanahan SHT Taylor, representing
executive producer Sheila Hanahan Taylor.
Beck Tires is probably a nod to set designer
Jeffrey Beck.
JB Dupuy is named after foreman James Dupuy.
Hey look.
It’s me trying to watch this movie.
Car 45six is a grey and black vehicle with
a big sponsorship from Bill Wall Leather.
This is a clue about the disaster, because
we saw Bill Wall Leather back in Final Destination
2 on shortly worn shirt of Evan Lewis moments
before his accident.
Andy is also wearing a Bill Wall shirt.
This car also has ads for Casey Moore Gasoline,
named after production secretary Casey Moore,
Bel Castro Performance Ignition after production
executive Dana Belcastro and Barnard Helmets
after director’s assistant Kim Barnard.
The pit stop guys have patches that say “Wolf
Cams”.
As I mentioned in the last episode, wolves
are a Mongolian sign of good luck.
Car 16 is the bubbly blue car with a sticker
that simply says Colin Grant, that's the name
of the storyboard artist.
There’s also a Vinitsky Synthetic Oil after
post-production supervisor Jay Vinitsky, Glatter
Tires after supervising production coordinator
Emily Glatter and Lehman something after associate
producer Tawny Ellis-Lehman. (That's one of the director's daughters.)
The overall design of this car could
be our clue about the accident that nearly
took Janet’s life at the car wash.
On the back, there’s an ad for Holmberg
Industries, named after production manager
Erik Holmerg.
Car 71 says Matthews on the back.
There’s a stuntman named Eddie Matthews.
He’s probably the one driving that car.
“Is it safe to sit here?”
“Of course.
There’s a fence there.
We’re fine.”
*deep breath* I guess it’s kind of a good
thing this line is at the beginning of the
movie, because I still have the stamina to
hear stupid stuff like that.
So I’m actually gonna let this one slide.
The trailers offer a couple more connections,
like Holman Exhaust, named after art coordinator
Sara Holman, and Dashnaw, named after second
unit director Jeffrey Dashnaw.
The spilled oil could be a callback to this
part from the first movie.
One of the warning signs is when Nick discovers
they’re actually at a memorial event for
all the past drivers who had passed away.
Like the Flight 180 memorial, most of them
are named after crew members with the exception
of these five.
In the stands, I noticed a woman with a blue
white and red striped dress, reminiscent of
the French flag.
We’ve seen this pattern a lot, because the
original Final Destination was supposed to
be Paris, France.
Other Paris references in the movie include
this French-style scooter in the cafe, the
very idea of a cafe is French and also a callback
to the first movie, the picture of the Eiffel
Tower in Nick’s apartment, this advertisement
at the cleaners is a sideways French Flag,
Lori has this idea about her and Nick’s
future plans...
“Lots of traveling like Paris.
Maybe some beaches.”
And George gets hit by an ambulance with blue
white and red stripes, just like Terry Chaney
was struck down by the bus in the first movie.
He also compares the premonitions to the feeling
of déjà vu, just like Wendy did in FD3.
“No, no,no, not that. It’s like deja vu.
My wife says that deja vu is God’s way--”
The name of the cafe that Nick, Lori, Janet
and Hunt like to hang out at is Death by Caffeine,
and this is the location where three of the
four of them would eventually meet their fate.
Next door there’s a tattoo / psychic parlor.
Psychics are often referenced in the franchise,
as the main character of each movie has a
psychic premonition about a potential danger.
The items on the menu are potential warning
signs that Death is coming for them.
The examples I could see were the Knockin’
on Death’s Door Latte, Deadly Espresso Macchiato, Iced Mocha Fatality,
Iced Vanilla Demise, Frozen Chai Casualties,
Last Exit Truffles (which are maybe a reference
to Final Destination 2’s highway pile-up),
River of Stix Biscuit (a reference to the
mythological boundary between our world and Hell), Afterlife
Muffins and Iced Fudge Ripple (RIP stands
for Rest In Peace).
The coffee cup logo seen here is also the
same logo seen at The Coffee Beanery from
Final Destination 1.
Both locations have someone getting hit by
a large commercial vehicle.
There’s also a Hice Pale Ale sticker on
the refrigerator, a callback to movies 2 and
3, where these Hice Pale Ale trucks were involved
in two of the accidents.
There was a stunt double named
Cassidy Hice on this one.
I guess stunts run in the Hice family.
If you look at the closed captioning on the
TV, you’ll notice the news report is posing
the question, “Are amusement parks going
the way of the dinosaur?”
This is probably a response to the accident
that took place on the roller coaster, Devil’s
Flight, in the previous movie, which took
place 4 years ago.
It’s hard to tell, but it’s possible this
is the same kid who was the ride operator.
Maybe he’s here applying for a new job.
In a later scene, there’s a framed photo,
containing an ominous sign -- the words: Last
Exit.
Nick and Lori go to the memorial for the lives
lost at the speedway.
There are pictures of some of the victims,
including... apparently the little girl from
the fire meme.
This movie continues the tradition of having
something wildly inappropriate happening at
each disaster memorial.
This time it’s this dude, Carter Daniels,
just dropping an N-bomb out of nowhere.
At least I thought it was out of nowhere until
I went back and realized he actually has a
swastika tattoo in the speedway scene.
At the memorial, he’s wearing a necklace.
It’s actually very similar to Evan Lewis’s
demon-tail necklace in the second one, but
this one is more of a hook, a clue about his
fate which involves him getting stuck on a
hook and dragged down the street by his truck.
That night, Nick sees some more signs in his
dream.
In the third one Wendy sees the signs in her
photographs, but in this one, Nick just has
more premonitions… which is not that creative….
But one interesting thing is how the words
“It’s Here” are hidden somewhere in
each vision.
In Carter’s it briefly appears in the fire,
in Samantha’s it’s a dark spot on a hair
straightener, in Andy’s it’s obscured
by smoke, in Hunt’s it can be seen in the
draining pool water, in Janet’s on the inside
of a pipe, in the vision for the movie theater
victims it’s in the fire… again… and
for Nick, Lori and Janet the words “it’s
coming” scratched into the table are now
crossed out because “It’s here”.
Another sign from that night is this photo
of Nick and Lori getting stabbed by this blade
that’s just sitting out, which is really
just taken directly from Final Destination
2, but it’s made a lot less subtle this
time.
The first individual death is Carter Daniels,
who’s driving while sipping a can of
Hice Pale Ale, just like the truck driver
when we were first introduced to the iconic
brand of Hice.
What is it about this brand that just attracts
the worst people?
The trouble for him begins when the horseshoe
hanging from his mirror falls and turns on
his radio.
I’ve previously talked about how there are
horseshoes in most of these movies as a symbol
of luck, because in Final Destination there
is a big emphasis on luck, chance and fate
all being tied together.
Other examples are Hunt’s lucky coin that
he drops before being killed, the die on Carter's locking mechanism, the boss of
the auto shop having a shirt with a horseshoe
and a shooting star, the brand of hairspray
in the salon is Sprinkle Star, and it shoots
up to dislodge the ceiling fan, the homeless
guy who throws away a lucky penny, and the
movie that Lori and Janet go to is in theater
13 (the unlucky number).
The song that turns on is “Why Can’t We
Be Friends?”
It almost seems like it’s supposed to be
a commentary about how Carter’s end is like
a punishment for being racist and not being
friends with George, however, if that’s
the case it doesn’t really fit in with the
other deaths in the series because everyone
else was innocent.
I guess the other Carter was kind of a bully,
and a lot of the Final Destination 2 characters
were on drugs, and Frankie is just disrespectful
towards women, but even these don’t have
any kind of lesson-learned moment like this.
I just find it kind of weird that Death would
take the time to basically tell him he should
have been better, but then again, he is by
far the worst person in the franchise so far.
In every Final Destination episode, I’ve
talked about how Death uses water or liquid
in practically every attack.
This movie is maybe the biggest example.
The race track explosion started with the
spilled flammable oil, Carter is a victim
of a leaky gas tank, Samantha asks for a glass
of water,
“Oh Deedee?
Could I please get some water?”
...which causes the aerosol can to slide into
the clutches of the hair straightener, the
series of events at the customs shop is set
into motion with this…
...Janet is nearly drowned in a freak-car wash
accident and Hunt is actually drowned in a
freak swimming pool accident.
The cowboy is crushed by an overfilled bathtub
that falls through the ceiling and the movie
theater accident is a result of more leaked
flammable substance.
That concept is really overused.
The last three characters are taken out in
a beverage shop, and Nick has one of his visions
next to a bus shelter ad for Clear Rivers
Water.
Clear Rivers is also the girl from Final Destination
1 and 2.
Watch this episode of Horror History for her
full story and analysis.
Speaking of water, I noticed a Wild Surf poster
in Nick’s apartment.
Before getting into the film business, director
David R Ellis was a junior pro surfer, so
this may have been a nod to his past life that literally
no one paid attention to.
The next sign is when Nick catches a reflection
of his ceiling fan in a mirror on the coffee
table, a clue about the ceiling fan that nearly
fell on Samantha.
The comb and brush tell us that the accident
occurs at a hair salon and these rocks represent
the rock that the lawnmower accidentally propels
into her skull.
I also just have to point out this magazine,
which covers topics like sex, sports, beer,
gadgets, cloths, cars and sex.
And also nuclear sex.
The next location would be the hair salon,
which has a hidden connection with Volée
Flight 180.
Throughout the Final Destination franchise,
I’ve pointed out several examples of Hell
and demon references.
The name of the hair place, Salon Dante, refers
to Dante’s Inferno, the famous 14th Century
Poem describing Dante Alighieri’s
journey through Hell.
The next victim, Samantha Lane, is with her
two sons after their soccer game.
Their numbers are 20 and 9.
Twenty times nine equals 180, the number of
Alex Browning’s infamous flight.
Across the street, a gardener pours fuel into
his mower -- one of the few fuel cans that
does not get lit on fire in the world of Final
Destination.
Based on his hat, it looks like he works for
Jaymes Tools and Parts, a reference to the
production designer Jaymes Hinkle.
It’s not a Final Destination movie without
our goth girl right?
I also love how the salon has this big old
framed photo of a pair of scissors.
As if it were not abundantly clear that they
cut hair in this establishment.
Another ominous sign is seen when the soccer
kids come back with Slushees, the same brand
that Ashley and Ashlyn had before they became
the latest tanning bed victims.
“I’ve got my eye on you two.”
Hopefully it was the other eye.
This incident seems to be an homage to what
happened to Billy Hitchcock in the original
Final Destination, where a piece of scrap
metal shot out from under the train to decapitate
him.
Gotta love this guy’s reaction though.
Yep.
Just another day on the job.
Nick soon learns that Death is one step closer
to him when he sees this article.
We find out that Samantha Lane, who the credits
fittingly list as MILF / Samantha, is actually
from Lakeview, which is where the hospital
was located in Final Destination 2.
There are many bad omens here: the ads at
the top are all about making your will and
planning your estate, and the related stories
are all about other disasters.
The bus crash on HWY 180 references both the
flight number 180 and the pile-up the following
year which took place on a highway.
There’s also mention of a Ferris Wheel disaster,
and not the first one that’s come up on
Things You Missed either.
It’s probably an homage to the amusement
park crash in Final Destination 3.
The URL of this article contains a 1/08, which
is also an anagram of 180.
The author of the article is Amy Michelle
Akin.
I’m guessing she’s a relative of prop
master Curtis Akin, who also appears as a
golfer at the country club.
The article claims the rock was moving at
light speed.
Yeah, I don’t know about that.
It also says the lawnmower guy is named Danny
Wall.
Not Carl.
I guess he was just wearing Carl’s shirt
or something.
Nick and Lori have their friends over to try
to explain what’s going on.
Hey, is that a Hice Pale….
Oh…
Another article tells the story of another
accident survivor named Pam Smith.
We find out that she was once acquainted with
Brian Gibbons, the farmer's son who blew up
in the closing moments of Final Destination
2.
A police officer on the scene was rushed to
Lakeview Hospital and pronounced dead by Dr.
Ellen Kalarjian, the same doctor who resuscitated
Kimbery Corman.
Nick and Lori do everything they can to warn
them, but Janet and Hunt are unwilling to
listen to their theories, and head for the
exit.
“Where are you going?”
“I’m gonna do what I do best.
I’m gonna go and get laid.”
Wait!
Take the magazine!
The scene where that happens through, is probably
the most ridiculous scene in the entire franchise.
So they’re in this closed off cabana at
a public pool, with little kids walking around
everywhere.
And there are people sitting like three feet
away, with the only barrier being this fabric,
which is light enough that it’s just kind
of blowing around in the wind.
And he’s literally yelling to go faster
and stuff.
There is no barrier to sound right here.
But in case, by some miracle, nobody could
hear them doing it, this chick makes it even
more obvious by putting the bikini back on
OUTSIDE OF THE CABANA.
So moving on, Janet has a pickup from Carver’s
Cleaners.
I think Carver is kind of a slasher reference.
She drives to the car wash to try to clean
off her windshield, and if you’re paying
close attention there are several clues about
what’s going to happen to her.
Look at the shape of her car.
It’s very boxy, almost like an aquarium,
and behind the steering wheel there are a
couple of small fish.
She drops her quarter into the sewer grate
so she’s unable to fit through to get it.
She suffers a similar predicament when she’s
unable to escape through the opening in the
sunroof.
There’s also a rubber duck in front of the
passenger seat, just another clue that this
tub is gonna be filling up.
Anyway, she does survive, but she comes out
of there looking like that Roblox music video.
Her car is picked up by Destiny Towing, the
same towing company that Nazi Carter worked
for.
That name, by the way, Destiny, indicates
the nature of the Final Destination world
where everything is part of Death’s design.
Back at the pool this little kid has a super
soaker called the flash flood.
It makes me wonder if this is supposed to
be a reference to the big storm at the end
of the first movie.
I already mentioned this when I covered FD2,
but in that movie we see a fish get caught
in the filter at the dentist’s office, which
is a scaled down version of what happens to
Hunt at the swimming pool.
Back at Nick’s house, he and Lori are trying
to make the place safe, and we get a glimpse
of his bookshelf.
The first publication in the stack is Hamlet.
This is technically a sign that -- spoiler
alert for Hamlet which came out over 400 years
ago -- everyone dies in the end.
We pretty much knew that though as soon as
we saw that it’s a Final Destination movie,
however, there would be some new surprises
in the Final Destination lore hidden in the
pages of the newspaper.
In every Final Destination Things You Missed
episode so far, I’ve explained how each
character’s name is an homage to an
important person in the horror genre.
Sadly, in The Final Destination, last names
weren’t really a thing.
But if we do some detective work, using the
original script, it seems that the plan was
once to continue the tradition.
I don’t really know most of the filmmakers
being referenced in this one, they aren’t
exactly household names, but I was able to
find them and confirm their contributions
to the horror genre because I already knew
to look for horror filmmakers thanks to the
other movies.
You can just look them up if you want to know
what they did.
Nick’s last name was O’Bannon.
This was likely a reference to horror writer-director
Dan O’Bannon.
Lori Milligan was named after Andy Milligan.
Janet Cunningham seems to be named after Sean
Cunningham.
Hunt Wynorski has gotta be for Jim Wynorski,
who made a lot of B-movies and horror parodies.
I know we’ve seen the wind associated with
Death before in this franchise, but usually
there’s a window open or something.
And I like how it just goes from a light wind
towards their faces to this freaking gale
force in the opposite direction but it’s
just entirely targeted at this full coffee
cup.
Like, the paper and the cardboard don’t
move at all, but the porcelain mug just jumps
off the table.
The spilled coffee stains this newspaper,
causing Nick to believe this is a message,
because only words “Through Action they
were saved” are left dry.
So he thinks his actions could save George
and the rest of them.
But what he should have been paying attention
to was the contents of this article, about
an out of control truck crashing through a
storefront to kill 3 students from McKinley
High School.
This is definitely the sign about Nick, Lori
and Janet’s death in the final scene of
the movie.
Like many others that we’ve learned about
in this episode, they were taken to Lakeview
Hospital, and like a couple of previous deaths
in the franchise, the driver was under the
influence of alcohol.
The name of that driver was Jason Koffeman,
a development executive on the movie and the
article was written by Art Schaefer, a co-producer.
The other articles don’t seem to be related,
but they do have crew reference easter eggs
of their own.
Thinking they can save George’s life, they
go to his apartment, and just walk inside
uninvited.
They eventually discover he’s been experiencing
the same phenomenon that we saw with Eugene
in the second movie, where he’s just physically
unable to kill himself because it’s not
his turn.
“I’ve been trying to kill myself all day.”
But it’s OK; when they tell him they saved
Janet, his attitude completely changes and
it’s all smiles and popping bottles.
I mean, your best friend still died a horrible
death a couple hours ago, but you’re over
that by now, right?
“I’ll get the cookies.”
After thinking they’ve beaten death, Nick
and Lori make plans to travel, similar to
Alex and Clear’s idea when they thought
they were in the clear.
No pun intended.
“Are you sure you don’t want to come to
the movie?
It’s in 3D?”
Oooh, so meta.
Nick knows it isn’t over yet when he knocks
over this book, which reveals, yet another
sign.
I’m not sure why he even has this book to
be honest, if it’s just the same paragraph
over and over again.
The Cowboy guy dies, so Nick rushes to try
to save his friends with the help of George,
who also dies.
This movie came out in 2009, so they couldn’t
have possibly known that 2020 would be the
deadliest year since the Holocaust, making
the address that George died at all the more
mysterious.
Meanwhile his girlfriend is buying shoes.
Wait Lori!
Don’t forget your pamphlet for 2 free music!
They head to the movie theater, where many
of the posters seem to be additional signs
of Death.
The one on the right here is a parody of Saving
Private Ryan.
The film the girls are going to see is called
Love Lays Dying, which is seen as a significant
sign because Lori is Nick’s love interest.
The female lead in Love Lays Dying is even
named Loretta.
Lori is sometimes used as a nickname for Loretta.
The image on the poster is an eye, and when
Nick sees it on the bus advertisement, we
zoom into the eye.
The major premonitions from the second movie
forward all end with the camera zooming out
of the visionary’s eye.
One of the other posters is for a movie called
The Death Part Two.
The font and color scheme look similar to
that of The Final Destination.
Remember when I covered Final Destination
2 and pointed out that “Hollywood jumps
on Flight 180 Bandwagon” headline?
My theory is that this might be the sequel
to Hollywood’s Flight 180 movie.
There’s also an advertisement on the popcorn
tub for an upcoming movie called ‘Til Death
Do We Part.
My favorite poster reference is this one,
for a sci-fi film called The Z Zone.
The poster is a parody of the 90s sci-fi television
series, The X-Files, but the connection goes
a little deeper than that, because screenwriter
Jeffrey Reddick once created an X-Files Script
called Flight 180.
It was rejected, and Reddick later adapted
it into a feature film called Final Destination.
The theater chain is called Tagert Theaters.
According to something I saw on Final Destination
Wiki, it was named after David R. Ellis’s
daughter, Tagert.
Inside of the cinema, a series of events unfolds
exactly like the events leading up to the
disaster at McKinley Speedway.
“Down in front!”
“Sir, move your feet.”
Could you imagine a theater employee interrupting
the movie to tell Shane Dawson to move his
feet?
"LEAVE ME ALONE!!"
The third parallel took me a little longer
to figure out.
A man’s ringtone goes off behind Lori.
🎵 Dixieland Ringtone 🎵
...to which Lori whispers to herself…
“Dixieland.”
After looking it up, I found out that this
was a confederate folk song in America’s
civil war.
America’s civil was a war against slavery.
Slavery equals racism.
The racist guy from the speedway was sitting
in a similar position in relation to Lori
as the ringtone guy.
And if you go back to that scene, he can be
heard whistling the same melody.
There would be a couple more Final Destination
throwbacks as Nick tries to prevent the disaster
at Tagert Theaters, including a fire extinguisher
that shorts out like Evan’s in FD2 and him
being attacked by a nail gun like Erin in
FD3.
The movie theater would ultimately not be
the death of Nick, Lori or Janet, but the
final chronological scene of the series would
offer a few more connections and secrets.
The first sign that danger is afoot as Nick
heads back one last time to the coffee shop,
Death by Caffeine is the bus that passes by
-- bus number 180.
Then, inside the cafe Janet is wearing a hoodie
with a cherry pattern.
We previously saw cherries on the necklace
of the hair stylist Deedee, and she was also
involved in a major accident.
Then the homeless guy who threw away the lucky
penny shows up and starts a conversation,
another omen of bad luck.
“OK, that was really weird.”
No, there was nothing weird about that.
I don’t know why you would call out one
of the few normal moments in this movie.
They all sit down together to have a drink,
creating a direct parallel to the final accident
in the first Final Destination with Alex,
Clear and Carter.
Like the Cafe Miro 81 accident, there’s
an issue with the scaffolding on a nearby
construction site.
And like that scene, Nick says essentially
what Clear said but with much more pessimistic
intentions.
“How do we know this wasn’t exactly what
was meant to happen?
That out of everyone on Flight 180 you me
and Carter were meant to live?”
“What if us being here, right now, was the
plan from the beginning?”
The scaffolds fall into the street, right
inbetween bus 180 and a sign that says
Dead End.
This would be their dead end.
Click the video on the left for the next episode
of Final Destination Things You Missed.
And make sure you’re subscribed to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring the deathbell
for notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one.
Assuming we both survive.
If you want to beat Death, use a facemask and social distancing.